today, it is fighting not only for
its territory for its sovereignty, but
also for all the democratic values ​​of Europe, and this must be understood
clearly, because
Russia will not stop at Ukraine, Russia
will go further and continue to advance on Europe. But
we want to say that we need a
concrete solution.  Actions for the reconstruction of
housing today Almost 6 thousand
families remain without housing And this is a very
large number, we are directly fighting, we are
fighting not only for Ukraine, I want to say once again that
we are fighting for Europe, but our
Ukrainians and to train the youth and those
boys who fought for  at the front and are fighting.
We are losing a lot, of course we
will try to do everything to make
life better, but first we
need to restore all this, it is a very, very big
job, because there is a lot of destruction and all the
resources of the state, and we hope for our
European partners, we need to
rebuild, of course, first  continue to do better and
better. I am sure that Ukraine is
European, will be a member of Europe of the
European Union, and we clearly show
that we are reliable partners